I had to see the usual audience at our
physics colloquium you may think that
I'm going to introduce Wolfgang ketterle
but you'd be wrong
I'm introducing dan kleppner dan
kleppner came to MIT after getting his
PhD and serving for some years on the
faculty at Harvard and he's really
famous for many of the things he's done
in atomic physics for rid Berg atoms
making atoms as large as thousand
angstroms in diameter for many other
things and and for his work with Tom
gray tack on bows condensation in spin
aligned hydrogen dan when he came to MIT
began the establishment of what is now a
truly great School of atomic physics and
the test of a great school is the
students and and several of those
students have won Nobel prizes Bill
Phillips in 1997 was a student of dance
and one of this year's prize winners
Carl Lyman did his undergraduate thesis
research with dan dan is a great
physicist a great educator those of you
who've taken 801 to know his wonderful
textbook he's a great writer he writes
columns and physics today that are
wonderful and he's great colleague and
it's my great pleasure to introduce Dan
so success has many fathers and some
grandfathers and today I am a very happy
grandfather and I suspect that Norman
Ramsey over here is a very happy great
grandfather
I had the great good fortune to have
dave pritchard as one of my first
graduate students and to have the
experience of him as a colleague at MIT
for many years dave has many
accomplishments this year he is mentored
directly two of the Nobel Prize winners
Wolfgang ketterle and Eric Cornell was a
graduate student of his he has made many
seminal contributions to physics he
invented the fields of atom optics and
he made seminal contributions to the
work which garnered the Nobel Prize in
1997 for atom cooling and trapping he
invented the AVI Pritchard trap he did
the seminal work on what's called the
MOT which is the workhorse in that area
and in 1990 he invited Wolfgang ketterle
to come as a postdoc to work with him on
atom cooling even though Wolfgang had no
background in that area he spotted
Wolfgang's qualities and the two of them
together did such fabulous work that it
was clear that Wolfgang was headed for
great things but not at MIT because we
could not appoint a young faculty member
who would be in competition with a
senior faculty member or who would
really be in close collaboration because
we expect our faculty to be able to work
independently Dave overcame that
obstacle by withdrawing from the field
and turning over his equipment to
wolfgang so wolfgang could start out his
work towards BOS condensation at top
speed and the rest of that is history
and you will hear more about it but to
me this example of mentoring which is to
leave a field in which were very
interested in doing outstanding work to
make room for young talent is in the
very best tradition of science and
teaching and I hope in the very best
tradition of MIT so it we this is though
with those thoughts I would like now to
introduce to you Dave Pritchard
well thank you very much Dan
bye my account this is the fourth time
that Wolfgang has given an MIT physics
colloquium here in the six years since
he's been on the faculty and August of
seven now this is a sign that while it's
actually in the past six years this is a
sign that MIT recognized his worth
somewhat before the Nobel Prize
Committee since I've had the honor of
introducing him three times I thought I
might just summarize those introductions
to give you an idea of his growth now I
know some of you were saying wait a
minute three introducers and now three
introductions but it's okay because we
discussed it and we realized that if
each one of us talked to factor of three
longer than the first than the previous
speaker and Wolfgang followed suit he'd
still talk for more than two thirds of
the time you can work that out so in the
first introduction I said Wolfgang was
my postdoc and we were fortunate to get
him here to take over running my cold a
/ cold atom apparatus because he can run
it so much better than I could that's
expected he has made fantastic progress
now having made a an observation of B EC
but with orders of magnitude more atoms
than the condensate that Eric Cornell
made a jello and the second introduction
not too much about a year later I said
Wolfgang is absolutely courageous with
the best VEC the biggest PC in the world
and with this phone ringing off the hook
with the invitations neither of these is
an irrelevant concern for a professor
who doesn't have tenure he decided to
scrap his magnetic trap he felt that a
new cloverleaf magnetic trap that he
designed would allow for better
scientific studies of the condensate as
usual he was right and so on so you one
of yourself that's a second the third
time I said Wolfgang ketterle needs no
introduction
[Laughter]
he was just promoted from assistant
professor to full professor in a single
jump and he justifies this by doing
spectacular research and so on and so
forth now what I hear the trite phrase
needs no introduction I often know the
speaker myself and I then agree of
course with the introducer but it always
raises in my mind the question well
who's this guy who's doing the
introduction doesn't he need an
introduction and at this fourth
introduction I see that the that the
relative stature of Wolfgang has grown
so disproportionately that many other
people are now concerned with this issue
and that obviously explains today's
format where there were two guys
introduced me occasionally I feel that I
should try to retain some of my
mentorship a vestige of that and so I
try to challenge Wolfgang to get even
better this is really difficult to do
because of all the people that I've
worked with which so far includes six
Nobel laureates he's the only one who is
a plus at absolutely everything
scientific taste design organization
group management writing scientific
talks public lectures a plus so
challenging it is like saying well very
good about jumping over all those tall
buildings with a single bound
but if you could learn to jump over
whole cities you wouldn't crush so many
automobiles now previously I've
challenged him by guaranteeing that he
would give a spectacular talk and
actually today I can raise the bar
simply by challenging him to do that
again because I know that this is a week
where he hasn't had much sleep and he's
had numerous distractions from the press
and from many interviews but I'm sure
that he's up to it one final note just
from from my personal perspective I want
to say that your most important a
possibility this is a colleague and
friend my world has been tremendously
brightened since you walked into my lab
and I'm glad to see that MIT is the same
way
[Applause]
what a place and what an introduction I
think you heard from the previous people
who introduced me what nice a place this
is what create meant was I've I've had
and sometimes I feel I was privileged to
finish what those people have started
and you will see that in my talk but you
I think you've also heard from those
introduction that this place and the
atomic physics community or the physics
department is an inspiring and friendly
environment and it is this environment
which brings the best out of us now dave
was raising the bar by saying by sort of
announcing an a-plus talk
I think this talk too for me has two
superlatives number one it is the best
attended lecture I've ever given but now
I'm embarrassed to say number two it's a
verse prepared one because I was given
very short notice and they thought so
well I just put a few new curves
together but the closer this talk came
the more I felt it's a very emotional
talk for me because this is my family
this is my place and I want to tell a
story and not just give a talk on our
recent results so I try to prepare
something special but I couldn't really
polish it so let me tell the story of
Musa instan condensates
which is the coldest matter in the
universe and since I know here support
audience I want to be explicit in one of
the concepts so the post condensate you
can regard it as meta made of metal
eaves it's a form of matter where the
quantum mechanical nature the wave
nature of matter manifests itself at a
macroscopic scale so you're all familiar
with the most of your hope with a
particle wave duality for light for
photons but we have the same particle
wave duality for all particles we know
from the early days of quantum mechanics
that particle which is classically
characterized by position and velocity
should rather be described as a quantum
mechanical wave at a POI wave and the
wave length of the deployed wave of the
quantum mechanical wave follows the
famous deployer relation it's inversely
proportional to the velocity of the
particle and I know when we learn
physics we all struggle with the concept
that particles are all objects you and
me and microscopic objects and
macroscopic objects are waves and
particles at the same time particles
propagate as waves but when we detect
them
it makes click in a detector so well if
you and me if we are all waves
why don't we perceive the wave nature of
matter in everydays life so let me raise
you let me raise the question how do we
perceive if something is a wave or not
so if I would challenge you and say
explain me why sound is a wave a very
reasonable answer would be if there are
two people who talk to each other they
can hear each other even if they don't
see each other because a wave propagates
effects around corners if I would ask
you what happens in the case of light
you all know that light is an
electromagnetic wave it's not so obvious
because the wavelengths of light is so
short that light is just deflecting a
little bit and you can't really perceive
the wave nature of light very easily but
now in the case of meta waves the
wavelengths are even shorter the
wavelength is given by the deployer
relation and the velocity of a particle
is determined by its temperature so from
that we know that the colder the
temperature the longer is set of oily
wavelengths now talking about atoms at
room temperature the meta wavelengths
the deployer wavelengths is smaller than
the size of an atom so therefore the
wave nature of atoms is not manifest but
now we can cool down and the title of my
talk is the coldest matter in the
universe we cool down to micro and nano
Kelvin temperatures more than a million
times :
Seiler space and the deploy wave links
becomes longer and longer and this value
is 30 micrometer is a fraction of the
diameter of a human hair so it's really
getting microscopic and these long
deployed wavelengths they are at the
heart of the phenomenon which I want to
describe bows are instant condensation
what happens if you take a gas in a
container and cool it down the particles
slow down as I just mentioned we
shouldn't describe the particles as sort
of little billiard balls they are wave
packets they're kinda mechanical waves
but as long as the wavelength is very
short those wave packets are very
localized and we can follow the motion
of those wave packets as if they were
particles but now we can cool down the
deploy a wave length becomes longer and
longer and when we reach the point where
the wave packets where the deploy waves
overlap then we cannot follow individual
particles anymore they become sort of a
quantum soup of of wave packets and it's
exactly at this point when the wave
lengths are deployed wave length is
comparable to the spacing of particles
that a new form of meta forms and this
is suppose our instant condensate or to
say it again if the deployed wavelengths
become longer and longer and those meta
waves overlap then all the particles in
the gas they start to oscillate in
concert and what they form is one giant
meta wave and this is suppose our
instant condensate just use an analogy
the difference between atoms in random
motion and the post condensate is
exactly the same difference as a light
from a light bulb and the light coming
out of a laser
so what bose-einstein condensate is
about it's about the creation of atoms
with laser-like properties and this is a
nice artist's conception of how you can
imagine the bose-einstein condensate
first of all these are in this in
distinguishable atoms you see they have
all the same facial expression and they
march in lockstep which means they are
face its a single wave function and this
is how you can imagine what happens in a
bose-einstein condensate you also see
sort of those other guys they walk in
random direction they are not posed
condense the and different quantum
states and are therefore distinguishable
from the atoms in the condensate now of
course what I just said that all the
atoms go into one Trentham state and
fall in lockstep is only possible for
atoms which we refer to as bosons
particle particles which have integer
spin I don't want to go into details
here but there's another class of
particles called fermions they have
half-integer spin and their behavior at
low temperature is completely different
so the phenomenon of bose-einstein
condensation can be regarded as the most
striking manifestation of quantum
statistics of the difference between
bosons and fermions and the name was
Einstein condensation is derived from
those two well-known people who
predicted it in the 1920s however
bose-einstein condensation in a gas was
not realized until 95 for reasons which
will become obvious in a moment so after
the proof so the prediction of Bose
Einstein statistics was 1925 and for
many many years the only manifestation
of bose-einstein condensation was in
liquid helium the super fluidity of
liquid helium is a consequence of
bose-einstein condensation but it's a
liquid it's not a gas and there are high
density effects which modify this
phenomenon greatly but then there was an
attempt to realize those are instant
condensation dilute gases and a lot of
credit for that should go to Tom great
egg and then kleppner
who are here on the faculty they really
put all the Einstein condensation in
dilute atomic gases on the agenda and
made it a goal and it's very pleased to
mention that after 20 years of efforts
they realized those are in
synchronization in hydrogen and achieved
a long-standing goal however a few years
earlier there were new cooling
techniques develop laser cooling
briefly comment on them and new systems
alkali atoms could be cooled to
ultra-low temperatures and it's really
the alkali atoms which have created this
whole new field of ozone Stein
condensation with many many activities
and the success here came in 95 and I
will tell you the story today so well I
think from those the concepts I've
presented if you want to achieve
bose-einstein condensation quote-unquote
all you have to do is you have to cool
down a gas to micro and nano Kelvin
temperatures if to cool it down until
the deployed wavelength is comparable to
the spacing between atoms and the meta
waves overlap and start to oscillate in
concert so I mentioned that the deploy
wavelength depends on temperature the
distance between atoms depends on
density so we haven't so the transition
to bose-einstein condensation is
characterized by a combination of
temperature and density so let's just
look at this relation for something of
the density of water you would predict
that the transition temperature is 1
Kelvin which is easy to beach however
tough luck at 1 Kelvin everything is
liquid or frozen and you can't observe
the phenomenon of those are instant
colonization so in order to prevent that
and also to prevent formation of
molecules out of the atomic gas we had
to work at extremely low density so the
system I'm referring to is at a density
which is a billion times more dilute
than water it's hundred thousand times
thinner than air and in those gases we
can observe bose-einstein condensation
without self-destruction by molecule
cluster formation and solidification but
there's a price to be paid if you work
at ultra low density you need ultra long
deploy wavelengths to make those meta
waves oscillate in concert so we needed
the lowest temperatures ever achieved so
we needed cooling methods and what I'm
actually talking about is the
combination of two different cooling
methods which were developed in two
different sub areas one is
cooling the pioneers of laser cooling
some of them were recognized with Nobel
Prize in 97 and major developments to
laser cooling were also done by Dave
Pritchard at MIT the principle of laser
cooling is fairly simple you shine laser
light on atoms the atoms scatter light
and if you play some tricks which I
don't want to explain that the light
which is scattered which is emitted as a
shorter wavelength is more energetic
than the absorbed light then the
scattering of light removes energy from
the system and the system cools down it
works great you just shine laser light
on atoms and you create micro kelvins
embers in a very important configuration
to do that is the one who invented by
Dave Pritchard and I think this is
probably one of the most important
similar techniques which were ever
introduced to the field of atomic
physics the magneto-optic trap it is the
workhorse of the whole field of
ultracold atoms now so well and if you
have this configuration of laser light
and shine light into a vacuum chamber
and add some atoms you see this is in
one of our lab upstairs you see a small
ball a few millimeter in diameter yellow
glow so you can see with the naked eye
ultra cold sodium atoms but it's a
fairly hot temperature of a fraction of
a million so this is the starting point
for the next stage of cooling towards
bose-einstein condensation laser cooling
has so far not been able to carry atoms
down to pose our instant condensation
because it has limitations and some of
them are very fundamental if you scatter
light from atoms each photon is
therefore photons are grainy it's like
sort of send cones which transfer a
finite recoil momentum to the atoms so
therefore the temperature of the
standard laser cooling methods is
limited to microkelvin
so well if you can't get very cold you
should get very dense because it's a
density temperature combination which
makes post condensation happens but
unfortunately there's also a danger
imitation laser cooling which without
going into details is simply set by the
pauses if you're very tense enter all
the laser light is absorbed and laser
cooling doesn't work so laser cooling at
least in the beginning of the 90s fell
short by four orders of magnitude in
density or three orders of magnitude in
temperature to each bows are in
synchronization so well this is
something which Dave which are developed
and I was opposed up with him but next
door is 10 kleppner who together with
from great egg and Herold has developed
evaporative cooling and this is a
different cooling method which is not
suffering from all the limitations of
laser cooling so let me explain what
evaporative cooling is actually before I
explain the slide evaporative cooling is
what happens in everyday life if you sit
in a bathtub the water cools down and it
cools down because the hottest particles
escape esteem and what remains behind
are the less energetic particles this is
called evaporation so well if you do it
in an add on trap if we confine atoms
with magnetic forces we create such a
potential it's like an invisible
container the walls of which are
magnetic fields I don't want to say more
about it right now but so if particles
in this container and if two such
particles collide one can lower its
energy come to rest these are the
particles we want to keep their really
cold and the more energetic one can
escape and this was suggested by Harold
Harold Hess and realized in the group of
ten kept nine from draytek so so if you
have a method to kind of eliminate the
hottest particles in many many steps and
the remaining particles is thermalize we
create a thermal distribution which gets
colder and colder and colder so the
question is how to implement it and Dave
Pritchard had a brilliant idea this sort
of
which so well it's even dripping with
blood here how can what what is a
suitable X for atoms so well if you're
in a magnetic trap there's a very simple
X and this is just switch the magnetic
moment of the atoms so that the
attractive force the confinement force
turns into a repulsive one you just have
to shine radiofrequency onto the atoms
and you have your X and you can do the
cooling so this was Dave Pritchard
suggestion in 89 so well here two
cooling methods developed by the people
who at the office next to me laser
cooling and evaporative cooling laser
cooling works great initially has
certain limitations but evaporative
cooling does not suffer from them so it
probably doesn't require rocket
scientist to realize it would be a good
idea to combine the best of two words so
this was sort of the idea in the early
90s but there was a problem which some
people regarded as fundamental and the
problem is that I mentioned that laser
cooling doesn't work when the example
becomes opaque when the light gets
absorbed on the other end evaporative
cooling requires collisions between
particles one particle gets colder and
one party gets hotter and now if we look
at the collision cross-section you face
a dilemma
we don't want light to be absorbed but
we want collisions to happen and the
difference the ratio of those collision
cross-sections effect of 1,000 so it
seemed absolutely impossible to have
many collisions for evaporative cooling
and at the same time avoid the complete
absorption of laser light a solution
which Dave Pritchard developed together
with me was so well we can modify we can
push optical cooling to higher densities
but just playing a simple trick if we
hide the cold atoms in a different went
home state so that the light is not
absorbed we can push laser cooling to
higher densities I don't want to go into
details but by modifying the standard
mode which Dave who invented
we realize something which is called the
dark spot and it was a key technique to
achieve post condensation both at MIT
and Ebola and I just show you the result
which at that point in 92 published in
93 was fairly impressive
we were shining light at a cloud of
atoms and the shadow was really black we
could infer that the transmitted light
was ten to the minus eighty eighty this
was absolutely black and so in 92 what
we had in our hands
was an unprecedented combination of high
density and large number of atoms and
then you told stories about me Dave
North to tell a story about you namely I
still I mean I remember those traumatic
days this was the summer of 92 and Dave
great shot he had funded were funded
proposals and he had great ideas to
study cold collisions to study old
molecule formation and eventually many
people got a lot of credit for that but
we had so this was the agenda and this
was the proposed work and this is what
the funding agencies had supported but
then we said together and decided maybe
we can do something else with those
high-density sample maybe we can go for
the very specular speculative and
challenging goal of bose-einstein
condensation and it was for me just the
signature of a great scientist the Dave
said okay I give up all my ideas which
were really great and which other people
got enormous credit for it let's do what
you suggest let's go for the long haul
let's try to go further and use this as
a starting point for the quest for
bose-einstein condensation and it was
very dramatic
within a few weeks even before
publishing the paper we placed all the
orders for additional equipment
necessary to do the next step to combine
laser cooling with evaporative cooling
so eventually we wanted to embark on the
agenda to use laser cooling as a first
step and then lower the temperature by
evaporative cooling and get to
bose-einstein condensation
so well we had to build a complete
machinery for that and it took 1 or 2
years to assemble it and then we were
sort of ready and try to see evaporative
cooling and this actually May of 94 was
an important step I went to a meeting
and announced for the first time that
laser cooling and evaporative cooling
had been combined by using this
high-density sample of atoms we could
bridge the gap between this factor of
thousand difference in cross-section of
light absorption elastic collision we
had seen the evaporative cooling and now
we were hoping to push further to lower
temperature but still we were five
orders of magnitude away from be easy at
the same meeting the Balder group
announced that they had accomplished
something similar so the vase went on
and was one of the most exciting races
of my lifetime and every cornell car
Wyman and myself we remain friends and
we talk to each other on the phone on
Tuesday and we both said to each other
you got the best out of me because if
you have competition you work harder you
think other and you do better work
actually at that point I thought it
could take the rest of my life to push
further incremental II and explore the
new physics which would come about at
higher densities and lower temperatures
and I knew that the quest for both our
Einstein condensation in concrete eggs
and then kleppner slab had already
lasted 15 years and I was expecting so
well we try know something alternative
and let's see which method works better
and to the big big surprise and it came
completely unexpected just one year
later bose-einstein condensation was
achieved it's one of the rare examples I
think where you think you do an
incremental step and you step forward by
a factor of a million so these were very
dramatic moments let me mention a little
bit about the last obstacles on the
finish line to bose-einstein
condensation so the combination of
evaporative cooling and laser cooling
was accomplished but in order to have
enough collisions between the atoms to
have good evaporation we
to keep the gas tightly confined so we
need it tightly confining containers or
magnetic traps now this may be a little
bit technical but some people are in the
audience who probably are interested in
that there are two types of magnetic
traps some have a pointy potentially
linear we shape potential and others
have a round potential at the bottom
those threats are more tightly confining
and that's what both the group involve
and at MIT used to demonstrate initially
evaporative cooling because it makes it
easier to get many collisions and sea
evaporation but they have a problem
there's a point of zero magnetic field
in the sender and if the field is zero
the atoms don't know what is spin up and
spin down they lose their orientation
and virtually flip out of the trap so we
lost the atoms it's like a hole where
atoms sneak out and the months before be
easy was achieved both groups had to
invent methods and this how it was
dubbed how to plug the hole every
Cornell scope in Boulder used an
ingenious method with rotating magnetic
fields and we decided to use a different
method we wanted to plug the hole with a
laser beam which was keeping the atoms
away from this dangerous region where
they would just fall out of the magnetic
trap so what we created was a potential
which has a hole in the middle and you
see here the shape of our clouds and it
worked great it was really traumatic we
could push forward orders of magnitude
towards bose-einstein condensation and
then this was a June of 95 we heard
about the boulder results they had
succeeded to get bose-einstein
condensation and that's maybe something
I don't know if I've shared it publicly
if you're an assistant professor you put
all your money all your resources all
your efforts on one goal and then you
are not young and then you're notified
that somebody else's accomplish this
this is a difficult situation
you wonder about promotion you wonder
about your scientific career and of
course I know at MIT the bar is very
high and mighty is not keeping losers so
I was really scratching my head I woke
up early in the morning what to do and
people asked me why don't you just copy
the design in Boulder and I mean this
seems to be a successful way to do it
and then a whole new field opens up and
we had fierce discussion in my event
what we did is actually a two-fold
strategy we designed a new magnetic trap
I will talk about it and this turned
into the workhorse of the field and this
has given us an enormous productivity
over the last few years but and I was
sort of willing to say let's just put
all our eggs into this basket let's
pursue that because this new magnetic
type is a really good idea and indeed it
turned out to be a good idea but I've
worked with a good group of people and
they told me so well this trap with the
plug maybe it will work or even if it
doesn't work because maybe the laser
beam is jittering and heating up the
atoms let's just give it one or two more
tries and that's really all let's just
figure out how far we have come because
the polder group has a big success and
we should at least document how close
became so well I try to listen to my
collaborators and said ok but just a few
times we can't waste time we don't want
to miss support and it was one of the
very last attempts to see how far we
could push with our original idea of
this optical plug trap that we saw both
are in synchronization this is a picture
which doesn't look nice but I want to
show it to sort of the experts this was
our first signal of bose-einstein
condensation on September 30 years in 95
we were not really ready to observe we
just wanted to see where are the limits
of the plug trap and for the experts we
couldn't switch off the laser beam so in
time of light the atoms were just pushed
away by the laser beam so it's not a
pretty time of light picture it doesn't
look as pretty as the other ones but we
saw something black sharp black spots on
the screen and if a cloud expands
ballistically
is compact that means there's very
little velocity there's very little
motion it's very very cold and we got
enormous ly excited and within a few
hours we worked throughout the whole
night we improved the setup and we got
clearer evidence that we had observed
both are instant colonization we were
running the experiment only one more
time to get final data and this is
actually for me still amazing this is
the quality of the data which was
obtained the second time we were ever
running the machine for both are in
synchronization let me just explain what
it means we let the gas go and it
expands out and then we take a snapshot
and the larger the cloud is the faster
is the velocity the what are the atoms
and now you see what happens when we
cool down you see how this cloud is sort
of shrinking because the atoms slow down
and this is sort of the last factor of
two the last fraction of a second to
achieve bose-einstein condensation and
then this new form of matter
this ultra cold gas which is suppose our
instant condensate forms it's very
visual it's very dramatic and we
obtained that without really optimizing
our machine okay so I mentioned that
this was a night on September 3rd years
and so well at MIT you have to teach an
October 1st I to teach 801 to I received
an email message from one of my students
now six years later as a freshman in the
fall of 95
I took your 801 to class I remember one
day when you were unusually late for
your lecture and you came rushing in
very excited yet very tired from the
previous night's experiment I think I
told the students I didn't get any sleep
at all and please if I fall asleep
during my class ask me a question
so well a few weeks later there was some
short reporting Tech Talk but this was
the night the boys are in
synchronization was realized at MIT okay
but immediately with our abort
we had hundred times more atoms and we
had a system which was more versatile to
pursue the new physics of bose-einstein
condensation this is a picture of the
group a few months earlier it doesn't
show Kim Davis but it shows the people
the other people who were on board
telling Durfee mark Mavis Michael
Andrews then stamp our current class the
unfunded NASA postdoc and Chris Townsend
joined a few months after we saw be easy
anyway we were playing I now tell you a
story of sometimes you do the right
thing for the wrong reason and this is
when we changed our magnetic trap which
is really the core of the apparatus we
were one of the two or three groups
there was a little bit ambiguous
observation by a third group who had
seen bose-einstein condensation and
everybody was priming with excitement
and I made a wrong assessment I said hey
it wasn't really so complicated what we
do in the next few months many groups
around the world will repeat it and now
have to be really careful maybe with our
jittery laser beam we're not competitive
we really have to go forward and make an
improvement and we thought let's build a
new magnetic trap what happened actually
is it took us five months to build it we
couldn't get any Bose condensation for
the next five months but when we got it
we were really going like gangbusters
but my assessment was wrong because
nobody else were post condensation in
the meantime indeed to build such a
complex apparatus it took two years for
all the other groups so if he had known
that we would have probably just stuck
to our original setup but we went
forward and created what turned out to
be a really good trap and which gave us
an enormous productivity so we realized
this trapping configuration which is not
suffering from this league it's sort of
a round bottom trap it actually carries
the name Yaffe Pritchard because they've
which had suggested that in the mid-80s
and we found a new way to bind a trap
it's now referred to as a cloverleaf to
happened so well this is how we are how
we have produced both condensates ever
since it shows you the actual binding
pattern and now I show you a few
examples of what we were able to do in
this trap it was an enormous ly
productive time and one of my graduate
students who was with me between 95 and
99 he graduated with 20 papers infusive
letter nature or science so these were
one of the first experiments we did in
this novel trap we could now visualize
the condensate inside the trap using a
novel light scattering technique and now
we could really observe what was going
on inside the condensate and here you
see the cool down our magnetic container
was elongated so it's an elongated cloud
and it shrinks as we cool and when we
reach the phase transition in the middle
of the trap we see this formation of a
dense core the bose-einstein condensate
and if you just take a cut through this
cloud you can see you know this you
remember the blue guys who march in
lockstep this is this peak and then you
have a thermal component these were the
colorful guys which we are moving and
whizzing around in all directions and we
did a series of experiments here you see
a condensate set in oscillation people
call it the study of sound and some of
those results what is the frequency of
oscillation what is its damping was
really posing major challenges to
many-body theory and led to hundreds of
theoretical papers or something which I
felt was very dramatic
those nano Kelvin atoms you think
they're so fragile it's cooler than
anything else but by using this light
scattering technique and just tapas copy
illumination we could really see how
color coded in red how a condensate
formed it was for me like watching how
nature is giving birth to something
which is very fragile but nevertheless
we were able to observe it in its
natural environment and actually the way
how the condensate forms
was challenging theory and over many
many years now
Quentin kinetic theory has been
developed to some extent to explain the
dynamics of the formation of the
condensate but let me now use talk about
two examples of our research which
really demonstrates what may expose
condensate so special now if I talk to a
lay audience so if I want to help you if
you meet your friends and you want to
tell them what is really special about
those are instant condensates I want to
now give you two examples how you can
convince people that this is something
which has unusual properties and it's
merely related to what I called here the
magic of meta waves and I want to show
you two examples the interference of
condensates which allow you to directly
photograph matter waves and I want to
show you the example of rotating
condensates which have a Swiss cheese
like appearance this is very different
from how any ordinary matter behaves
okay what I want to explain you now the
interference between condensates was
actually a key experiment which we did
and it was also actually one of our key
contributions which was emphasized by
the Swedish Academy because what we
could do in 96 and published in 97 was
we could show for the first time that
the condensate is not really cold
so while coldness is relative but then
it has these special properties that all
the atoms march in lockstep that they
are just one train to mechanical matter
wave okay if you want to show that
something if you want to show for
instance that this laser beam is an
electromagnetic wave the best way to do
it is you take two laser beams and
interfere them and then you see an
interference pattern the in
feelin's is the clear evidence for the
wave nature so we needed to condensates
and so well by using a laser knife and
cutting a condensate into two pieces for
going all the details we created two
condensate and so now we had two
condensates and we switched off our
magnetic container and the condensate so
well if you switch it off the
condensates fall down due to gravity but
they also expend because of zero point
motion and atomic repulsion so what we
are hoping for is as the two condensates
expanding to each other and overlap to
see the wave nature of those atoms so
let me show you what we expected to see
so let me just give you an example for
the interference between two sources so
assume that this is the antenna of our
favorite radio station in Boston and it
radiates radio waves and now we bring in
a second radio station and now the waves
of the two radio stations interfere and
now you see the interference pattern and
of course the interference pattern
becomes more macroscopic the clothes are
the distances and at least those who
took 803 they should realize that this
interference pattern has the form of
parabola because a parabola is a
mathematical curve for which the path
length difference to the two origins is
constant but so well
we are not interfering radio waves we
are interfering matter waves so we have
our container the atoms spread out and
now I have to remind you probably of the
pretty much the similar equation I
showed you the deployer relation the
faster the atoms are the shorter is a
rapport wavelength so if we have a puff
of gas and let it go and then take a
snapshot the atoms which are further out
they have moved there faster and the
atoms which are closer in they are
slower so the wave pattern of such an
pulsed meta wave looks like this the
meta wavelengths is longer where the
atoms haven't traveled so far and it is
water where they've traveled further so
now we interfere our two bows are
Einstein condensates and you again see
now as we bring them closer together
that there is a distinct interference
pattern but in contrast to the two radio
station this interference pattern
consists of perfectly straight lines and
when we observe the overlap of the two
condensates and we saw that we were
really jumping up from our chair Center
and I think I remember the first night
we saw that again we had worked until
the wee hours in the morning I think it
was you then you came in at eight or
nine o'clock at eight or nine o'clock
and I was almost drunk and I came to the
ends of his then I have to show you
something and then came to the office
then came to the lab and we had this
pattern on the screen so we knew the
post condensate is a coherent form of
matter actually just to talk in terms of
Labor s'en what you actually see here is
seek or two things one is this is a
direct observation of the wave nature of
matter we simply take two puffs of atoms
they overlap and then we illuminate the
atoms with a laser beam and we take a
shadow image there is not it's the most
direct observation of the wave nature of
matter but secondly this is also
demonstrating in a fairly dramatic way
this equation that atoms plus atoms
gives vacuum because where there is no
shadow there are no atoms so the two
meta waves have interfered each other
way atoms plus Adams gives vacuum I mean
I Saunders get fan mail from you know
people who have their own theories of
physics and
and I got some questions about your what
happens with uni he laid Adams by
interference but I think you all know
the atoms which are missing here they
appear in the dark fringes because atom
plus atom equals four atoms if you have
coherent interference okay so this is
just a different more fancy
representation of that at about the same
time we found a trick
to release atoms out of the magnetic
trap we were just sort of spin flipping
atoms they were accelerated down by
gravity and so within a few months we
had done two things we had shown that
the atoms are lays alike and secondly we
were able to create pulse beams of atoms
and this together was is now recognized
as the first realization of an atom
laser an atom laser which emits atomic
matter with laser light properties and
other groups have followed and improved
on that so this is sort of an at-home
Lisa Kelly Kelly continues at home
lasers and in different ways it's it's a
rich field and there is a lot to be done
let me now talk about this other example
and where the wave nature of matter
really becomes manifest and this is
actually related to a very special
property of the Bose condensate the post
condensate is sort of one giant meta
wave and it's possible for a wave-like
matter to move to propagate without any
friction there's one similar system
which has enormous technical importance
and these are super conductors in
superconductors electricity can flow
without any dissipation you can switch
on a ring current and the ring you can
go home and months later the ring
current still flows without any active
power those phenomena are usually dubbed
super super conductivity for electrons
super fluidity for liquid helium and
here we have a system which was
predicted to be superfluid but it's a
gas it's eight orders of magnitude more
dilute and liquid helium so we have the
most
system in our hands to understand
details of superfluidity or microscopic
random phenomena I don't want to go into
details and rather emphasize one aspect
which is fairly directly connected to
super fluidity but I'm not really
explaining it and this is the physics of
vortices now I think you're all familiar
with what it is this is a vortex on a
very large scale you see a hurricane of
the coast of Florida I think we also
encounter vortices in our everyday life
at least I could used one today you
simply push the button and you create a
vortex so what is special about vortex
physics okay there's something important
difference and that's what I want to
explain let's consider this rotating
pocket experiment and I want to show you
that there's a dramatic difference
between what aiding and ordinary fluid
let's say a bucket full of water and
rotating what I call a Quentin through
it and this is the system where all the
particles are just one big wave first of
all if you rotate a normal fluid you
know that upon rotation it forms this
parabolic surface because of centrifugal
forces if you take for instance
superfluid helium and you do the same I
just told you there's a big difference
but the same happens it's a parabolic
surface and it has to be like this
because on large scales there's a
correspondence equivalence between a
classical system and a quantum system
but if you now look little bit closer
onto the quantum system you will find
that the system is riddled with tiny
little holes tiny little vortices so
there's a big difference and I want to
explain that will the reason is the
magic of meta waves
we're not asking particles to go around
and go around we are asking waves to go
around and due to the laws of quantum
mechanics we have a snake of waves and
the snake has to bite into its tail it
has to lick it has to form a closed wave
so there
with the quantization condition that we
need an integer number of the poi
wavelengths around the circumference so
that means now if you rotate the packet
the classical system just rigid body
rotation has a velocity which increases
linearly with distance but the phantom
flew with the quantum gas cannot do it
because it has sort of to make a
decision zero matter waves around the
circumference one two three
so some something has to go in jumps one
possibility would be that we have a
region where the system is not moving
this means zero matter waves here we
wonder boy waves here too and here free
but a little bit more detailed
consideration tells us that instead of
forming this kind of ring shaped
geometry it rather the system harder
breaks up into little whirlpools little
vortices and around each vortices we
have one full deployed wavelength now
this is a very Universal consequence if
we have matter which is a single wave
and indeed there's a very important
experiment on twenty years ago at
Berkeley where this phenomenon was
demonstrated with liquid helium and also
with post condensates recently a group
in Paris showed this effect I'm talking
about recent work so I want to talk now
about things which were done in our
laboratory less than a year ago so we
try to sort of go further and study
further aspects of it so what we did is
and this gives you sort of a taste what
happens in building 26 it was this tiny
little cloud in a big vacuum chamber and
then we use a laser beam and we rotate
the laser beam around the cloud and with
the laser beam we are spinning up the
gas and we are setting the gas in
rotation and then if you let the gas go
if you let the cloud ballistically
expand we can now compare the cloud
without rotation it's just the blob
which expands as I've shown you before
but with rotation
we observe those whirlpools so this is
again a very clear manifestation of the
wave nature of matter ordinary standard
substances would not behave like this
and again it's the most direct
observation it's a cloud which rotates
you let it expand you take a picture and
this is a shadow the shadow of this
cloud actually this is amethyst
emulation by one of my colleagues which
shows that this structure of whirlpools
is preserved upon expansion of the gas
we can't directly photograph the cloud
while it is rotating because the
structures are too small but by simply
switching off the magnetic drive and
everything expands we get almost we get
a magnification factor almost 4/3 and
the faster we rotated the cloud the more
vortices we observed so this is an
example of a vortex lattice which is
perfectly irregular this is just a more
fancy representation but let's just look
at this very regular vortex lattice with
those lines which guide the eye we see
how perfect nature is but it's not
always perfect I know if you look
carefully on the left hand side you see
a lattice defect you see a dislocation
and extra row of
vortices so we have now a system it's a
very dilute claw gas and we can now
study the properties of what is he study
the dynamics and there's a lot of
interest in doing that but finally let
me talk about something which is even
more recent and some work which is
currently in focus and this is ok I will
tell you in a moment this is related to
optical trapping I told you that our
workhorse is a magnetic container but so
well
magnetic containers are nice they've
allowed us to do all this work but
they've also the limitations because if
you want to move magnets you may have to
move all the magnets around you can only
keep atoms in spin up States and not
spin down states so there were many
reasons to
put those most condensates into other
containers and this is a container which
is not using magnetic field but electric
fields and it's the electric field of a
focused laser beam we call it optical
tweezers because it's really like it's
like a laser pointer we bring the light
to a focus and this focus sucks atoms
into it just by electric forces so a
couple of years ago we showed that we
can transfer condensate from the
magnetic trap into an optical trap but
our piece of pride and our latest
accomplishment is that we are now able
to use this optical trap as a transport
mechanism for post condensate
so by taking not really the laser part a
lens and translating it we can move the
focus by 40 centimeters so our group is
now the unique ability to form a
condensate in one vacuum chamber then
focus laser light on it and translate
the focus by about 40 centimeters and
carry the atoms in a new chamber so we
are now able to deliver condensate with
precision through pinholes and put
condensates into whole new environments
close to surfaces into micro traps in to
resonators and there's enormous
excitement and let me just show you one
of the results this is 40 centimeters
away from where we produce the
condensate and here it is and it is less
than a millimeter away from a surface
and we think there's a lot of future of
atomic physics in that some people dream
that we can take atoms guided metal
waves on on atom chips tiny patterns of
wires on a surface and we guide the
atoms around like in an ordinary chip
electrons are guided and this may allow
us to have new geometry is to find new
properties of quantum systems but it may
also allow us to build precision sensors
for rotation
but I think this example also for the
last week Sounders demonstrates some of
my surprises when we were hunting for
the post condensate we thought we would
be so happy if you would just see it if
you would get there but now we can take
condensates transport them over 40
centimeters we can keep them for a
minute and do experiments we can spin
them at high rotation and see those
vortices
so the system is enormous ly robust and
allows to branch out in a large variety
of studies so for me the post condensate
is now an new laboratory to do all sorts
of physics to do condensed metaphysics
vortex nucleation sound densities which
i extremely know that it's very easy for
the Yogi's to calculate the effect and
what I've done here is it's more for the
experts I've just listed major
developments in the field which have
happened just this year and there are
other exciting things and I think
there's more to come
so it's a privilege for scientists to be
in the middle of something like this to
be able to contribute to the basic
concepts and see the scores of a field
and see how its branching out actually I
don't have a slide for that but one
question which almost everybody asked me
what is the application what will come
out of it now
my take on that is twofold one is it's
fundamental research and we do
fundamental research to learn about
properties of nature to find properties
of metal ultra low temperatures to
understand microscopic window mechanics
on the other hand what we are doing here
is we are learning how to manipulate
atoms the building blocks of nature with
unprecedented precision we have quantum
control over the atoms we control their
wave properties and this unprecedented
control over atoms may lead to precision
measurements may contribute to
nanotechnology or let me speculate even
further may find uses in quantum
computation but this is
The Horizon and collaborators and other
groups are exploring that and future
will tell what is possible but if I look
backwards usually if something basic is
done our imagination is not sufficient
to predict what it is good for so
finally let me acknowledge the people I
was really privileged to work with I
think the best team of students and
postdocs in the whole world this lists
the people who have left the group and
contributed to the work but here's also
a long list of people who are currently
carrying out this exciting work usually
I show a group photo but I realized we
haven't taken a group photo recently so
we are just asked the people who are
working with me just to stand up and
it's a live group photo and they're
carrying out this work and ladies
thank you
enjoy
well that was fantastic Wolfgang you
lived up to expectations are there any
questions okay it's just fine
I don't think there have to be any
question we have a reception in the marl
our lounge I just want to add on behalf
of the physics department of course this
is an unbelievably exciting occasion
we've had five Nobel Prize winners in
the last 30 years as I told my
colleagues I'd like the rate to go a
little higher but I cannot imagine a
more wonderful person to receive the
prize than someone who not only has this
passion for science but can convey it so
beautifully so let's end just by
thanking Wolfgang one more time
you